[Musique]
miss france miss ronde miss élégance les
concours de beauté sont nombreux en
france miss normandie
pour y participer il faut souvent réunir
des critères précis comme la taille le
poids l'âge un nouveau concours a décidé
d'ouvrir ses portes à toutes les femmes
qu'elle soit mariée tatouée ou ayant eu
recours au bistouri importe quelle femme
de france pourra participer si ce
concours intitulé miss esthétique
présenté par la candidate de
télé-réalité milla jasmin et par jean
michel maire est plutôt une bonne
initiative un détail remet en question
toute la crédibilité de ce concours la
grande gagnante remportera énormément de
choses ce détail c'est la récompense de
la gagnante 15000 euros en opération
chirurgicale et en soins esthétiques
pour ceux qui le veulent et ben ils ont
comme mission de faire une chirurgie
esthétique ou pas pas de quoi valoriser
la beauté naturelle des femmes alors
faut-il interdire le concours miss
esthétique
jean michel maire est avec nous merci
jean michel maître de ses rives du
concours miss esthétique shelly frais
influence heuzé jury du concours miss
esthétique merci à vous donner un
plaisir c'est vrai que voilà je vous le
dis il y en a beaucoup qui sont pas
d'accord et on sait bien que vous soyez
là et que vous en donnez vos arguments
c'est vrai que ça réagit déjà énormément
beaucoup ya hubert guérin spécialiste du
concours miss france et auteurs
commencent à valberg
shebab aussi tulle embrassera de ma part
et il ya jean michel cohen notre médecin
nutritionniste jean-michel merci d'être
là parce qu'on voulait avoir aussi
l'avis d'un médecin là dessus alors pour
cette toute première édition c'est jean
michel maire don qui sera le maître de
cérémonie il sera accompagné de la
candidate de télé-réalité milla jasmin à
la présentation on va là où l'on va
réussir à m
je vais regarder elle critiqué les
critères du concours se sont contre son
comptable
ceux qui connaissent pas miss esthétique
en fait c'est un tout nouveau concept
donc c'est un petit peu comme miss
france sauf que c'est complètement
différent c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
critères de beauté où on pouvait avoir
entre 18 et 40 ans tandis que par
exemple les miss france après vente par
exemple je vous inscrire j'avais la
chirurgie esthétique vous pouvez pas
vous inscrire et en fait ça c'est pour
les lire donc la plus belle femme de
france mais sans qui aucun critère de
beauté vous pouvez faire un mètre
soixante vous pouvez faire 80 kg vous
pouvez avoir 39 ans vous pouvez déjà
avoir eu deux enfants sachent est
vraiment long le casting est ouvert à
tous alors voilà donc elle à l expliquer
donc les règles de ce cette miss cette
histoire de miss esthétique alors
pourquoi on est aussi inquiet c'est
qu'il ya 15000 euros d'intervention
chirurgicale a gagné et qui dit
intervention chirurgicale dit parfois
qu'on rattache est d'ailleurs l'un des
gros risques lorsque des personnes qui
n'ont pas les moyens dans des dans des
cliniques spécialisées vont chez des non
professionnels regardez là par exemple
cet exemple
attendre bouge pas là la thalie ibos
niveau du nez est ce que tu te calmes et
reste encore du produit ce que tu veux
tu t'es injectant petit peu au niveau de
là c'était vraiment niveau de là je
crois deux semaines après placé
catastrophe totale une gauche comme ça
mon nez il a triplé de volume pour
menton des formes et sarah consulté un
chirurgien
diagnostic ses lèvres sont infectés elle
risque la nécrose de discuter ce n'est
pas de la stern comptait injecter de
l'huile
de coco et son état va encore empirer
cette claque là en fait elles ont éclaté
en plein la cgtu mais vous savez c'est
vraiment lui le sahara a porté plainte
mais n'a pas donné suite trop de
contraintes
alors ça c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
j'ai aussi un autre exemple dans sans
aucun doute sur tmc on a vu le
témoignage d'adn à 27 ans elle a voulu
refaire sa poitrine après sa grossesse
même chirurgien a complètement raté
l'intervention garde rina 27 on a eu
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
après deux grossesses je me languissais
de l'enlever ce pansement pour voir le
résultat et puis bang des aides et qui
me l'a enlevé belle surprise totale j'ai
regardé
voilà pour la visite à la ville ocre
watts tout plat sur le dessus tout vide
et toute la masse qui ressemble à la
jeune femme qui rêvait de retrouver sa
féminité est aujourd'hui d'autant plus
complexe et tu peux plus je peux plus
mettre tout ça
je peux plus rien mettre d'accord on
sort tous les habitants
voisins dit appelant au quotidien voilà
alors on va montrer d'autres exemples
dans un instant donc ce concours miss
esthétique faut-il l'interdire
gilles verdez vous dit tout bien sûr
qu'il faut l'interdire et une ambiguïté
extraordinaire dès le départ vous dit en
gros chez nous il n'ya pas de règle
venez comme vous êtes qui que vous soyez
et puis le prix malins des prix ces
quinze mille euros de chirurgie
esthétique ou de soins sous-entendu
venez comme vous même et nous on va vous
transformez je trouve ça discriminant
pour l'image de la femme c'est une
publicité déguisée pour la chirurgie
esthétique ma question que je voulais
vous poser est ce que vous êtes finances
et oui ou non par l'industrie de la
chirurgie esthétique dans ce cadre d'un
concours national répondait je
me laissais paribas répond depuis
journée c'est un concours voilà qui
n'exclut pas la chirurgie esthétique
c'est un concours qui rompt avec les
archaïsmes des anciens concours de
beauté où il y avait des concours qu'on
a souvent moqué ici de taille d'âge
cetera qui était complètement d'un autre
temps hélas cette fois ci il suffit de
se sentir belle ola de parler français
d'habiter dans un pays francophone et
d'être majeur c'est tout après on peut
avoir un piercing ou pas vrai tatouage
on peut avoir fait la chirurgie
esthétique la chirurgie esthétique ne se
limite pas non plus aux implants
mammaires aux implants fessiers et les
poussions sustraia pleine opération de
chirurgie esthétique et quand je les les
non mais qu on voit les images d'avant
filet raté camiade raté chez les
dentistes et chez les journées et les
mauvais choix et des mauvais dentistes
des mourides pour minorer animateurs
mais l'avancé voilà voilà c'est pas
financer la chieuse cette éthique et
quand on dit qu'il ya 15000 euros il ya
de baignade les milliards de cadeaux ou
d'ailleurs ça c'est une partie des
cadeaux à vrai dire je vais dire les
cadeaux tout à l'heure mais bon c'est
alors que deux minutes deux minutes
parce que y'a hubert guérin spécialiste
du concours miss france et auteur qui
voulait réagir qui est très énervé alors
oui moi je suis très en colère contre ce
congo en fait je suis une extinction de
vaud mais quand j'ai vu ce concours j'ai
instantanément perdu ma voix en fait le
projet même principe dans le concours
c'est qu'il ya des critères exclusif
vous n'avez strictement aucun critère
mise à part le fait de se sentir et
française par là pour un concours de
beauté se sentir vote il ya pas mal non
mais d'accord mais il ya des critères de
beauté objectif qui permette de se
présenter à un concours de beauté donc
là sous prétexte ans passe sous prétexte
de concours de miss vous faites en
réalité la promotion de la chirurgie
esthétique
il n'ya qu'un critère de beauté il faut
faire un mètre 72 c'est à dire que non
je dis pas mais jusque-là définition
même d'un concours c'est qui est des
critères qui soit exclusif on n'est pas
face à un concours vous dites que vous
allez promouvoir et indémodable motards
ont dû vite que vous allez promouvoir la
beauté dans sa diversité la rue des
fabriques dire quoi pour toutes les
jeunes femmes qui sont justement
originale de la diversité qui ont été
élues miss france je pense à sonia
rolland miss france 2000 ça veut dire
quoi pour sophie vouzelaud miss france
de 1re dauphine de miss france 2007 et
qui était sourde et malentendantes qui a
permis de faire avancer la cause est
aussi je voudrais vous répondre sur un
autre point vous dites que vous allez
faire un concours pour incarner la
diversité
énormément de concours de beauté en
france qui permettent les ses montagnes
ses rimes qui permet
[Rires]
des femmes qui font moins d'un mètre
soixante dix j'ai des concours pour les
fans qui font monde cadets concours pour
les fans qui sont qui ont un handicap
oui ça existe donc à vous chercher tout
simplement à faire la promotion des
insurgés ces tic c'est un concours de
miss parce que les miss a fait polémique
et ça rassemble mais c'est inadmissible
alors on va voir juste guillaume genton
très énervé il va vous répondre dans un
instant juste jours et vous montrer un
petit truc trouve à vue ce jeune homme
qui a fait le buzz dans le monde entier
fans de kim kardashian elle a dépensé
plusieurs milliers d'euros pour lui
ressembler regardez le résultat
j'ai du botox dans toute la tête entre
les sourcils entre les yeux j'ai l'élève
le front le menton le nez refait les
gens me demande tout le temps combien
j'ai dépensé pour tous a sûrement près
de 100 mille dollars j'ai dépensé
beaucoup d'argent et je continue
ça a commencé il ya quatre ans quand je
regardais l'émission sur les kardashian
et quand la sextape de kim venait de
sortir elle est devenue une grosse tard
elle a une vie des oufs et énormément de
followers
j'adore les selphy j'aime vraiment les
selphy
je n'arrêterai jamais si je suis heureux
maintenant j'ai vraiment envie de voir à
quoi je ressemblerai dans dix ans ça
vaut le coup et vous aimeriez vous venir
faire de la chirurgie avec moi
[Musique]
c'est pas
la médecine et des soins esthétiques et
sa presse de la thalasso n'importe quoi
la co-présentatrice claude jasmin on
pense pas des soins thalasso à djerba
jolies
jantes en est très énervé lui l'adn est
révélateur et là il est très heureux qu
est ce concours non mais en vrai déjà ce
qu'on voit c'est des cas extrêmes et je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut vivre
avec son temps et je pense qu'à l'heure
aujourd'hui où il ya une française sur
dix et ya eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique je trouve ça cohérent qu'on
puisse mettre en valeur ces femmes qui
rappelons le sont totalement exclues des
concours comme miss france c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi une
fille délaissée enrobé dans le héros
fait mais qatari n'a pas été brillant
dans le panneau qui a le monopole des
critères de beauté c'est le comité miss
france non et c'est très bien que c'est
très bien mais la route est très
positive victime mer calme toi non alors
pourquoi
en revanche quand on organise un
concours de beauté on met en place ses
critères pour justement de créer un
concours de créer une compétition l'aïe
a strictement aucune paix si on met dans
le vent c'est bon c'est bon jean michel
cohen non tu tombe dans le panneau serre
dans leur présentation du concours il ya
le côté noble c'est à dire on prend tout
le monde les gros les petits les meubles
et les ceux qui ont un tatouage et c'est
tout ça c'est pour masquer le fait que
si tu adhères à ce concours est situé
lui mit alors à ce moment là tu vas voir
plein de choses à ta disposition en
priorité quinze mille balles pour faire
tout ce que tu veux en esthétique toutes
les gamines qui fréquentent les réseaux
sociaux est là mais la regardant et
super fille qui se présente avec des
supers d'edel rêve d'être comme ça donc
elles vont y aller vous allez avoir peur
les candidats plein plein plein de
candidats avec l'espoir de faire ces
quinze mille balles de chirurgie
esthétique en plus on leur fait des
promesses vous leur dites oui tu va
voyager comme levi's fond ce qui va
faire le tour du monde dans ses bottes
pour les attirer mais d'un côté ce crime
de la non-discrimination et derrière il
ya le fait oui mais jean-michel ce qui
m'étonne c'est que tu aurais dû
l'omission toi qui est un pro b stature
et de la chirurgie plastique à
l'implantation à mer etc ça peut être
dans le non pas du tout les 15000 euros
et pour être fait par exemple pour
recoller des oreilles pour faire des
choses sinon père nevin yanit complexe
parce qu'on réduit toujours aller une
pollution bonne fête où ça s'est passé
je sais qu'elle est l'opération qui se
fait le plus en france à l'heure
actuelle c'est l'opération pourra voir
des jolies fait son temps de la grèce et
août la leaf est on en oublierait me
dire que saint trois ans après il faudra
probablement
des
miliciens d'al je vous aime beaucoup
mais là vous foutez de notre gueule
quand vous dites me ce concours
esthétique ces sous-entendus chirurgie
ce titre il
[Applaudissements]
ya déjà plus de 6 ans fait déjà plus de
600 personnes qui sont instruits main
feront sur nexus où il m'a trompée
alfaro l'inscription
sacomi de france
sur les 600 personnes sont chers jeunes
filles qui sont inscrits la 98% à ce
qu'on tienne et comme des statistiques
qui n'ont jamais fait une seule
opération de chirurgie
c'est moi alors pourquoi messieurs
allawi s'était que ça veut dire la
beauté
est à lier tous les autres j'appris miss
france miss prestige équivalent en fait
maintenant faites votre compenser comme
miss france mais sûr qu'on peut avoir
fait de chirurgie esthétique on peut
avoir à peut être pas vraiment toi je
peux avoir fait des photos de charme
avant ses salles
fétiche souple est un des lots oui c'est
donc quinze mille euros pour bien
souligner qu'ils doivent guider les fics
d'accord pourquoi ne pas tout comme
gilles et quand bien même avec les 15000
euros elle ferait la chirurgie
esthétique qu'est ce que ça peut faire
la chirurgie esthétique ça permet pas ce
que je te le donne et a réussi ça permet
d'enlever des névroses et de rendre des
gens heureux
et de bien vivre à d'autres c'est pas
magique enduire faire
l'exemple à ses premiers points ils ne
s'aiment pas pourrait jouer là dessus au
moins contrairement aux miss france là
c'est un vrai critère où on est honnête
et on dit tu es bon tu y lit sinon parce
que les miss france nous faire croire
que c'est sur des valeurs qu'elles sont
sur une plage avant à ce qu'elles sont
gentils est ce qu'elles ont une culture
alors qu'on s'en fout on le voit les
délires unique autour du physique c'est
tout c'est le concours des bisounours tu
peux pas dire ça bah c'est moi je je me
dois air m'interroge pas dangereux mais
moi je l'appuie et ne culpabilisez pas
les jambes j'avais l'accord relevé la
tu vois bien et pardon mais miss
esthétique pardon c'est ce qu'on appelle
vraiment une âme mot qui est inquiet à
qui appelle quelque chose dans
l'inconscient et s'appelle effectivement
la chaussée alors on en des îles 21,6
euros
parlez pas de sens si l'on sait jamais
où elle vivra avec son pain vous dites
n'importe quoi ça veut dire quand il ya
un mal être c'est pas parce que tu fais
une personne qui sait où il cita les
oreilles très déco les répondants table
oui ça comme quelque chose j'ai sinon
c'est louis et les ruelles et reculait
et tu vas faire de plus en plus non non
non cela montre qu'on a monté son secret
de
dire une chose je moi à 19 ans geron
film j'ai tué ma provence
à dix avant j'ai refait ma poitrine
parce que j'étais j'ai fait 38 kg un
moment dans ma vie et j'ai tout perdu
mais je me sentais plus femme la porte
quand j'étais jeune ça c'est un vrai
critère bellavance a blessé la première
dame était tout c'était chaud alors
c'est fini je dis voilà donc si tu
cherches j'ai refait ma poitrine et ça
m'a fait du bien et grâce à ça j'ai pu
ranger
vous avez fait quoi comme chose c'est
tout ouais mais l'élève si c'est ou non
dubès n'avait rien fait au nom si vous
mettre à profit les cheveux j'ai fait
des paupières etc je suis très content
de l'avoir fait et je le regrette jamais
amusant non mais alors
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît jouez
vous montrer un autre truc au continuer
je voudrais montrer des images voilà
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya 15000
euros de chirurgie et de soins et de
soins esthétiques à gagny regardez cette
jeune femme qui ne veut même plus
ressemblent à des stars de télé-réalité
mais carrément une poupée gonflable
regardez ces parties très
mon rêve ultime est de ressembler un
sextoy humain avec des traits parfaits
exagéré
quand j'avais huit ou neuf ans j'ai
entendu parler de la chirurgie
esthétique
m equinox et que ça pouvait changer ton
apparence et depuis j'ai toujours eu ce
sentiment que quand je grandirai jean
ferrat high rider en finlande ils ne
font pas de chirurgie avant 18 ans donc
je suis parti en estonie pour avoir ma
première augmentation mammaire
avoir des implants était le meilleur et
c'est un gros que
ça passe et aussi des gens qui sont
tatouées comme des les akan et c'est pas
pour ça aussi qu
il ya de plus en plus de lire et yoplait
géraldine maillet interdire le concours
pour vous ce concours c'est une
mascarade alors jean-louis je me
souviens toi tu avais fait le tour des
teens d'heure et tu t'es dit m
d'abord un combat mais qu'on fasse un
concours d'abord sans critères je suis
d'accord avec monsieur il ya toujours
des critères pour un concours aidé à
financer quelque chose il ya une taille
à un âge
mais je sais pas moi enfin je fais moi
par mes toiles sont d'accord dire que
dans ma vie en fait donc j'allais faire
un conflit les zooms année et à une
femme de 40 ans qui est obèse est très
belle mais obèses avec le projet canal
bah je sais pas je me pose pas la
question d'un ben j'imagine que vous
avez moins de 40 ans oui donc vous
pouvez participer à ce concours mais
elle avait participé à miss france
impossible déjà parce que je suis petit
donc du voyage et imaginez-vous presque
c'est toute ma vie en fait petit du
voile petit je regarde l'émission miss
france et je me dis mais mais jamais de
ma vie je pourrais pas ce que je fais un
mètre soixante c'est pas possible et
pourquoi pourquoi je n'aurais pas le
droit de participer à mes seins parce
qu'en fait qu'on se mélangent tous en
mélangeant fait c'est juste ma peau
côtoyaient les dégâts hier matin chez
les critères quand on est mal car
vous êtes
si une somme de cas alors j'ai pris joli
mais j'ai pas le droit de faire miss
france j'ai malgré l'interdît pour moi
parce que c'est une finale on se rend en
souabe genre habib sy a par exemple une
fille de 40 ans par exemple qui obèses
et tatoués et qui est très joli et qui
va défiler pour ce concours ou gens me
sera maître de cérémonie à côté de vous
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle et les
chances de gagner mais pourquoi pas mais
non je vous demande
crise les gens ne sont pas fous quand tu
te présentes un concours est doté donc
ça veut dire que tu portais des critères
hubert et un point extrêmement important
que vous abordez géraldine dans les
concours de beauté et la question de
l'égalité des candidates pour tf1 c'est
littéralement un enfer le soir de
l'émission pour que les candidates
soient traitées devant la caméra à
égalité là il n'y a aucune égalité entre
les candidats comme le dit geragos vous
allez peut-être vous présenter si vous
êtes candidate face à une dame de 40 ans
qui sera obèse donc ça je pense que
c'est un point extrêmement important et
qui de toute façon décrédibilise
totalement le concours et sur le
deuxième porte monnaie je suis d'accord
avec mathieu sur le fait que la
chirurgie esthétique peut permettre dans
une certaine mesure à des personnes de
se sentir mieux en revanche on ne peut
accéder à comparer ce concours
naissances en france 50% de l'émission
le compte est basée non mais enfin quand
vous appelez miss des miss et ses tics
france les terminaux france faudra qu'on
y verra si c'est un concours de beauté
est ce que nous acteurs
j'aime bien ce qu'a dit guillaume sur le
fait qu'il faut ouvrir à tout le monde
parce que c'est vrai que parfois miss
france c'est un peu chiant parce que tu
es faut faire un match 70 il faut pas
avoir eu d'enfant faut pas voir un
tatouage dans le dos et c'est bon ça
pour lui pour le concours il n'y a pas
de problème c'est ouvert à tout le monde
que je reproche à ce concours en
revanche c'est que si tu arrives à
ratisser pas ce que tu dis non les gens
de 40 ans ils n'ont pas s'inscrire les
gens ils vont être contents de
saint-sever parce que justement ceux qui
sont mal dans leur peau ils vont
s'inscrire en dix ans à la fin je vais
gagner quelque chose dernier quinze
mille balles ce qui me dérange mois
alors a bien voulu vous fassiez un
concours sans les 40 balle parce que si
tu as dix mille candidats tu prends
quatre cent mille euros passage sans les
partenaires donc en fait vous fait ça
que pour faire de l'oseille finalement
bien aimé le nom qu'on me sens ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher en font ils trop
grosse et
évidemment vous êtes embarqué dans un
truc comme ça à faire à faire croire aux
gens qu'ils mais que c'est le premier
ici à râler contre le fait que quelqu'un
une jeune fille qui avait fait des
photos de charme mais dix ans plus tôt
c'était lamentable pour l'exclure
je vais vous dire ce qui
m'inquiète dans cette histoire c'est
qu'il y en a une qui va gagner il y en a
plein qui sont venus contrairement à ce
que vous dites pour aller gagner le lot
des quinze mille balles point était
d'ailleurs ses fils a ensuite elles vont
fantasmes et encore plus sur l'histoire
des soins esthétiques ou de la clinique
esthétique elles vont aller voir un
orgue annoncera des crédits ça se fait
dans toutes les cliniques une
intervention qui n'est pas tout de suite
pas forcément obligatoire mais qui est
une opération qui les fait fantasmer
dites moi maintenant si les quinze mille
euros c'est pas une clinique qui les
donnent dites le moi si oui ou non
comment par la leaf a lancé peut-être
mais quand on
s'est accroché sur un dix sur
j'aimerais qu'on demande à delphine
parce que des titres et a même été miss
france est ce que vous auriez femis
esthétique vous non je vois pas famille
ses tics mais a pas
assez bons il faut un minimum de
critères comme marcel belle non attends
il faut c'est pas pour l'heure l'homme
l'interdire en tout cas non alors une
fois me nomme et minimum de critères
communs pour pouvoir avoir un outil de
comparaison si elle ne peut pas comparer
on ne peut pas en élire une femme à
paris c'est le jury qui va voter donc je
ne peux pas comparer un des gabarits
deux femmes différentes décennies des
sociétés
moi je vous dis stop c'est la page vous
dire là là delphine au contraire je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec marc cherry
j'ai vraiment aimé moi au contraire je
suis tout à fait d'accord ça aurait dès
qu' il faut au contraire qu'il y ait
justement des grands des petits oui
grosse démo à
tous et des mères de famille des gens
mais sera tout les mêmes produits
c'est le point de départ je suis
d'accord avec votre point de départ
c'est la chute et il va pas voilà
chitsaz hiatus avait complètement le
point de départ c'est vraiment parfait
je suis convaincu que mam ne venez comme
vous êtes mais à la fin j'ai changé
parce que comme vous êtes plutôt
semaine de
l'allier moi il ya deux choses qui me va
bien première effectivement c'est que
maintenant que vous aider dans les
magasins très souvent voyez des
mannequins qui sont qui ce qu'on déforme
et au sein de la bonne est en train de
changer c'est là que jean michel vous
êtes vraiment vraiment de mauvaise foi
c'est que la plupart des gens qui
veulent vous voir vous nutritionniste
jean-michel allez on va dire deux cas
sur 10 c'est la mauvaise le visiteur
sommes échangées c'est pour ces pour la
santé mais le reste c'est pour être plus
beau mais il ya un malaise mais je pense
que moi je prescris de l'alimentation la
même chose mais en lice aux jeux mais
pas un coup de bistouri sur quelqu'un
avant de lui faire subir une anesthésie
générale j'évalue le profil
psychologique de la personne pour savoir
si sa relève vraiment de son corps ou si
sa relève plutôt de son psychisme nous
les nutritionnistes on travaille avec
des kinésithérapeutes et des
psychothérapeutes et les psychanalystes
voilà ce qu'on fait là c'est pas le cas
et et toi tu prends le truc comme au
premier degré comme si c'était un truc
sincère moi je te garantis qu'à la fin
du concours il y aura un panneau pour
dire si vous avez envie de faire quelque
chose on me fera des tarifs des
suppositions
diffamation
vincent michel on se connaît trop c'est
une arnaque votre truc reconnaissance et
une harmonie c'est miss chirurgie
esthétique s'est mis au geste et si tu
veux si tu vires
été interdit mais laissez moi finir vous
avez plein de jeunes femmes ou de femmes
qui vont venir vous voir uniquement pour
connaître à voir les 15000 euros et donc
vous allez les transformer et donc sans
que jamais on ne sait pas aux n aurait
pas la seule industrie esthétique et
c'est très dangereux ce que vous faites
je pense même que vous serait interdite
avant le concours ce
qui m'énerve mais en général c'est qu'on
sous-entend que la chirurgie esthétique
et donc par extension ce concours créé
des complexes mais qu'est le concours
qui créent des complexes et un concours
ouvert à tous ont dit venez comme vous
êtes où ces miss france qui est le
concours le plus discriminatoire du nord
a
lancé on dit à dimitar essais et
notamment des petites filles voilà si tu
es belle tu dois faire plus d'un mètre
75 et que tu dois être célibataire et
ses deux filles comme madame cuisine je
suis pas belle et donc sans complexe et
miss france
à castaldi
pour finir il y a plein de il y a plein
de concours différents il y a le miss
ronde plus maman mm sd camille
cabral mittal a misé gros sur tf1 dans
cinq ans on atteint
il ya des concours différents avec des
critères communs pour pouvoir avoir un
outil nous comparaison donc pour moi
j'en milla ce que tu fais c'est un
concours fourre tout surtout avec un
titre hyper grossier parce que tu m'as
tu fais l'apologie c'est vrai le fait d
ouvrir une fois mais c'est pas grave
c'est faire croire à des jeunes femmes
et à des moins jeunes femmes que
l'effective mans le gros lot et le gain
est le super beau cadeau c'est d'avoir
quinze mille euros de chirurgie
esthétique faut quand même faire pas mal
d'intervention pour les rentabiliser et
pourront utiliser les 15000 euros il
faut rappeler aux jeunes filles que
c'est pas parce qu'on a une bouche comme
ça qu'on sera plus heureuse bien sûr les
gens là qu'on a vu aujourd'hui il
ressemble quai à kim kardashian dont dix
ans kim kardashian soit plus qui s'est
au final à quoi vont ressembler à ses
agents mais j'ai déjà dit une question
moi je trouve que la cause est noble
mais la seule question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas
que ces termes en nombre et par
l'industrie ah oui de surgy c'est le cas
effectivement même si
ferrer préféré quelque chose de mettre 2
voilà ce que ça change ça changerait
je trouve que ça change tout parce
qu'effectivement derrière ça il faut me
dire voilà nous on est on est on ne peut
pas faire de la pub à la télévision peut
pas en faire en radio on a trouvé un
moyen de se faire la promotion ce qui
est pas du tout honteux effectivement je
trouve ça plus et même des concours de
chant il se fonde sur usa maison de
disques
je connais votre défense de fer contre
les gens qui brûlent
c'est bon c'est bon on ne peut plus mal
c'est vraiment c'était pas possible de
faire le même concours sans que dire aux
gens de même 40 euros
pourquoi cette expliquez-nous les 47
pays nous a saoulé que ça je suis déjà
ça donne le droit à avoir une place un
public et le droit de vote c'est à dire
que l'été dernier afin de tout les
inscrits pour ce qui est de payer 40
euros elles peuvent voter en fait aussi
porte quoi c'est usant
[Applaudissements]
40 balles jean michel maire de laval et
fred aussi
tous les concours dont coûte de l'argent
la veine on écoute tu étais invitée à la
soirée de prestige qui sera pas fait
prier dans une grande salle à pigalle et
le droit de goûter aux
sinistres ont fait tu fais miss font ça
coûte beaucoup plus que ça
quand tu étais assez rigoureux les frais
d'inscription sont gratuits et les
financements les droits d'inscription
sont gratuits également une sélection
régionale qui donne lieu à des galas
auquel tu t'inscris tu payes ton dîner
ta famille un extra ça apporte beaucoup
plus d'argent 39' route faut bien aussi
fait une sélection pour tout n'y est pas
tout le monde n'y en a pas des masses
qui menace criminelle libère facteurs
tels que j'ai juste le mot à dire sur mr
on vous dit que le chemin c'était un
concours discriminatoire mais miss
france est un concours qui quand on est
petite fille comme vous l'évoquez la
petite iq garnis seront sept se dit pas
ça m'aide chez moins d'un mètre 70 soit
jamais si la
préfecture compte elle a 18 ans quand
elle a compris elle ne se présente plus
mais c'est mais c'est le pain c'est le
principe d'un fonds cours est par
ailleurs les concours de beauté au un
objectif c'est de faire la promotion de
quelque chose miss france est
l'ambassadrice de la beauté des riches
ont énormément concours dans l'histoire
il y avait par exemple miss d'honneur
aux états unis en france jouant mal ou
portable ça existe qui avaient stagné
pour ambition de faire la promotion d'un
produit la miss esthétique france
résumant à cet objectif l'ambition c'est
faire la promotion de la chirurgie oui
mais ça c'est inadmissible la moto et
berne tu es région le codapa grève n'a
pas besoin du concours fin septembre sur
ya de plus en plus de gens deux sévriens
recours oui on
a des missiles et imberbe sc federer
béchir est là j'aurais juste qu'on
finisse avec jean michel maire jean
michel maire oui moi je trouve que
j'avais mal compris au concours
maintenant vous m'avez expliqué je
trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
appréciable ce concours que ce qu'on
pensait va si c'est juste un concours
qui est ouvert à tous bien sûr voilà je
sais me esthétique c'est juste voilà que
vous soyez petit convention voilà et est
juste il ya des soins qui sont faire de
la chirurgie mais tu parles non mais
c'est vrai on égale si moi je croyais au
départ que ces années sont un mythe
chômage assedic c'est à dire la dame la
plus voilà
très déçu pour son jeu mais fait j'ai
fait c'est juste un critère comme un
autre et après ça pourra évidemment
permettre à certaines personnes jeunes
filles de résoudre un complexe qu'elles
ont amené les l'on s'appelle des
chirurgies pensé à toi fait mille donuts
et puis voilà
[Applaudissements]
tu es assez d'accord inquiété
du tout pour ce concours vraiment
je vais non mais je vous le dis non non
mais juste le seul petit truc s'est
récrié range énormément ses 15000 euros
mais
c'est que ces quinze mille euros voilà
pour pour le précieux message ainsi pas
paru